[موسيقى]
يتجه العراق نحو التصحر والجفاف بحيرات لم
يبقى لها اثر انهار جفت واخرى في طريق
الاختفاء سناخذكم الى مراكز القرار ونبحث
عن الاسباب الرئيسيه لجفاف العراق
[موسيقى]
نبدا مهمتنا بمنطقه الاهوار العراقيه التي
سجلتها اليونسكو عام 2016 في لائحه التراث
العالمي الاهوار ومنذ الاف السنين كانت
مركزا لتربيه الماشيه وصيد الاسماك ولكن
اليوم وبسب الجفاف يعاني اهلها من الجوع
وعدم قدرتهم على الحياه دون مائه
[موسيقى]
نعم نحن حاطين بحسه معاناتنا تعبانه كلش
والله حتى شوفوا عشتنا كانت على السمت على
الحشيش نبيع حشيش
حاله تعبانه كلي
د بس المايك
[موسيقى]
يعني لا عندنا وظيفه بالدوله لا عندنا شيء
لا عندنا راتب وانت تشوفون حالتنا بعد
ونتمنى الدوله تسمعني
راح سمك راح الدوام كلها موته كان عندها
30 جاموس الساعه
وقت الشغل
[موسيقى]
يعني
تفضل قهوه
[موسيقى]
ال ااه جاموس من شان قبل قبل
العلف رخيص الماء المتواجد
هسه بهذا سنتين
قبل فتره واحد معي ورجع هسه صار سنه سنه
ونص
يعني هسه
[موسيقى]
معي بشختوره يحطون
الحمر شفتوها حطونها
دموع العين
[موسيقى]
الحلال